he is one of the voices that you hear
and enjoy
quite a bit on the highly popular
podcast around the nfl
he is greg rosenthal here on the rich
eisenhower how are you sir
i'm good we plugging back into the nfl
the time
there's every day for me sir there's not
a day where i'm not plugged in
it's the greatest i uh and i can't wait
to talk all 32
and every single aspect of this
um of this season i just find is going
to be that much more intense
certainly since the mvp of the league is
still an open question
what do you make of roger's latest
comments about working on
self and the voice in the room that's
the loudest isn't sometimes the most
knowledgeable and things of that nature
what do you make of that
well i think he's saying he's the most
knowledgeable possibly um
but i think he's been on this journey a
while you know i think of this podcast
he did
years ago i i really recommend people go
check it out i was with pete holmes the
the comedian
um and he must have done it five or six
years ago when he was spending summers
out here in la
and look he thinks different than most
nfl quarterbacks he has been
trying to master his own mind and and
you know relax in his words uh as as
well as possible
and so i think it's just that journey
that he's been on and i like it like i
think back to these
the old 60s and 70s like books about the
nfl by dr
z and stuff like that and the characters
like namuth and everything that they had
at quarterback and the crazy things that
they would say to the media
all the time and it's like i always
wondered like what what if quarterbacks
were like that now and i fear like aaron
rodgers is that guy so i i don't really
put too much into it other than
he's taking some me time he's trying to
get ready for the season well then the
question is is what what does the season
look like i mean at some point rubbers
got to meet rhode you know
where all um all i guess pressure points
lead
to beginning of training camp first
preseason game
second preseason game then obviously uh
the week to ten days before the opener
uh against the saints um how do you see
this all playing out what are you guys
talking about on your pod and think how
it all is going to work out greg
rosenthal
i i thought the the soft deadline you
know
throughout was the training camp and
then
the real deadline is the preseason and
you mentioned it like right before the
season is closer to the hard deadline i
don't think there's anything jordan
loves gonna do
that's gonna change the equation like it
doesn't matter how well he plays
i still think it's a money thing the
fact that the the packers were trying to
negotiate
at the beginning of the off season uh
and that essentially
rogers got extra mad when he wasn't
happy with the terms that they were
trying to negotiate tells me it's still
just a negotiation and then as upset as
he is
i listen to the voice of our colleague
james jones or
or roger's former teammate john kuhn if
they think it can
be settled i i tend to think it'll be
settled and i do think
he's never he's not playing anywhere
else i i would be absolutely stunned if
they did anything but
ice them for a year or come to a new
agreement and to me that that new
agreement as annoying as it's going to
be to talk about for the next two months
is probably most likely
you know the week or two weeks before
the season that's how these things
usually well the new agreement has got
to have terms and dollars that keeps
um uh him the starter and jordan love
from getting on the field for any sort
of significant evaluation to pick up a
fifth year
option um and i agree with you i don't
think he goes somewhere else this year
either
because the the idea to trade him to a
spot
for draft choices that are only going to
get worse
for the packers because rogers will
undoubtedly
uh make those draft choices get further
and further away from first overall
based on his play
makes no sense as opposed to letting the
team that wants rogers now
go the season without him and have a
fixed terrible draft spot for them um
you know uh i guess a a a higher draft
choice for the packers
um so i don't see that
but they would have to have rogers
understand
that he would have to stare down the
barrel of not playing and i think that
might actually harden his stance to be
very honest with you
greg yeah i i do too and that's why i
haven't you know
given up on the idea that he will be sit
out this season
that they will you know go into the
season at the very least with him
um on ice but if they just guaranteed
money
one extra year i tend to think if it's
enough money
that that is a happy medium and this
thing didn't go nuclear until they
essentially went
back to him after he had just done the
mcp
season and tried to move money around in
his contract in a way that didn't give
him any extra money
in an additional year and that was the
point where as much as you know
everyone's sick of
hearing aaron rodgers needs and talking
about that's like
yeah i'd be i that's the moment that you
should be furious if you're aaron
rodgers like
even after the mvp they were essentially
you know entering a negotiation with a
low ball
offer uh that didn't make any sense but
the fact that they started it
that way makes me think that in the end
um
they're willing to make this happen and
they're willing to give them the money
and they are not willing to go watch him
uh succeed with another organization
because to me that's that's by far the
worst outcome for mark murphy and
everyone that's how you get fired
so then i guess last one for you on this
greg before we move along and talk about
other
uh nfl subjects then do you you know
so then based on on that supposition
and i think it's wise and i think you're
you're you've come up with
uh something that does appear to be
fixable or workable
that does not touch um the world
of uh grocery shopping right
because right and demanding a say in
grocery shopping or getting rid of the
the main grocery shopper for the packers
and brian guniquins
but i guess that's the end of my wind-up
now here's the pitch
um for for rogers
to accept that that means the packers
would have to put it on the table why
wouldn't they have put it on that table
already
have they put that on the table and
rogers is now doing this whole
uh offseason making them wait
and stewing because if they were willing
to do that before like why wouldn't they
have done that already
greg it's a great question that there is
a
a chance here that their they've got
their heels dug in but i just look at
all these negotiations
like over the course of time and as much
as we think aaron rodgers is special in
quarterbacks
you know i've heard this before like
think they're special in these
negotiations they're still just players
and ownership or in this case you know
mark murphy their president and the gm
treat them as players and it doesn't
happen until the last second like i
think of the javon walker
uh negotiation way back in the day which
went on forever
and it it they don't make their final
move until you get closer to the
deadline and so
uh i i think i think they'll do it i
don't think there's any way that they
want to go into this season with jordan
javon walker one where where farv chimed
in in the middle of it right
and told walker to get into camp
remember that
i love it i love i love how we're just
history repeating
ourselves once again rogers rogers knows
it
and uh i think he'd love to play for
another organization maybe he can get a
promise too that it'll only be two years
you know that's essentially what tom
brady did
at the end of his patriots career as he
did it in such a way that he knew the
year that he would have freedom and if
they can do that with rogers maybe both
sides are happy
greg rosenthal here on the rich eisen
show from the around the nfl podcast
which you can get where all podcasts
are acquired what's the story in the nfl
we're not paying enough attention to
greg um i'd start with justin herbert i
don't know why maybe it's like his
demeanor
maybe it's the fact that he played for a
pretty lousy chargers team
but you would think a guy that i i think
arguably had the greatest
rookie season uh by a quarterback in nfl
history
and and you could you could argue
roethlisberger you could
maybe argue rg3 there's a few other ones
over time that that are in the mix like
you would think he would have a little
more
hype because he did so many of the hard
things last year in terms of plays under
pressure like difficult throws
it was the easy things that he wasn't as
good and that's what you can improve on
from year one to year two like to me he
he's the most fascinating player to
watch at least for me because to me he
could be right there alongside mahomes
as like
the two great quarterbacks moving
forward and yet i don't get the sense
like
nationally there's a lot of like herbert
excitement well that's because they're
they're in southern california greg
right and the rams are the ones who made
the big maneuver for a quarterback
this offseason firing the first shot and
the stafford with the rams has certainly
got the rams i think
rightfully uh filled with bandwagon
jumpers
um and you know the chargers are always
the chargers no matter how
you know how terrific their quarterback
may be there's always something that
happens in the last 90 seconds or nine
seconds of a game that is the most
chargers thing possible
you know whether it's you know melvin
gordon fumbling three different times on
the goal line in tennessee a couple
years ago or what happened in the
first week uh uh uh first home game this
year of terrad taylor getting the shot
to the lung and then herbert comes in
which is
kind of like i guess their mo lewis
moment potentially based on how
much you're talking about herbert and i
think rightfully so i'm hearing that
they
love the new coach they love staley and
that's a totally different atmosphere
within that building which is another
reason why i like the chargers this year
yeah i love staley too everything i hear
about him and he's got the defensive
talent there as long as they don't get
hurt you know this is the time of year
this is chargers hype season and i've
fallen for it before
i was the biggest phillip rivers fan and
they pretty much
wasted philip rivers career by not
having an offensive line and injuries
and bad luck and defense but their
defense should be great
their offensive line and what they've
done to rebuild it on paper we've said
this before but it's never looked this
good
looks so much better and yeah i i do
think like just in terms of watchability
not enough people
got eyes on herbert and and the stuff he
did
to me was like andrew luck as a rookie
but better or russell wilson as a rookie
but
better and and that's like what gets me
going is watching young talent
greg rosenthal here on the rich eisen
show um
what do you think the patriots season
looks like
oh i think more than likely
mac jones plays sooner than later i i
think they're giving
cam newton every chance that he possibly
has
but i don't necessarily think you look
at all the these pickups that they had
in free agency and just like slot them
in for 10 or 11 wins like it is a
passing league
and it's great to have two tight ends
and it's great they're going to play
some hurry up
offense i think at the end of the year
you saw them play very fast
a year ago with cam newton i think
that's the type of offense they want to
run whether it's newton or mack jones
uh and they added a ton of talent on
defense and dante high power returning
is
massive yet i i don't see them as like a
top
five roster i don't see them as a top
ten roster you're counting on the
coaching
to make up for a huge difference and i
think we saw last year what coaching
uh can do i think they were they were a
three or four win roster that won seven
times and they
they were maybe the least talented
offense in the entire league and i i
don't think just a bunch of free agent
moves are
kind of like solve that the bills to me
are still a pretty heavy favorite over
the middle east
what do you think justin field starts we
know we had matt nagy on the week after
the draft and
you know he's like i was there when i
watched mahomes sit for the entire
you know uh first season with the
exception of the
final regular season game because there
was alex smith and that's the plan that
we have for justin fields
sitting behind annie dalton i even
pushed back to basically said i don't
know if you're gonna have the
uh latitude to be able to pull that one
off and he kind of even admitted that he
might not
but that's still the plan as we're
sitting here the tuesday after july 4th
what do you think about justin fields
greg rosenthal
yeah i remember breaking down those
quotes from your show on our show
perfect for helping us out and i
remember like he added the caveat
essentially you know things can change
like that's our plan but things can
change and one of those things that can
change is
justin phil's looking much better than
andy dalton in the preseason in training
camp and there's a lot of reasons to
believe
that could happen you look at the week
one match up against the rams you know
on sunday night football just as a
football fan i'm hoping field gets out
there for that game but it wouldn't
shock me
if they give dalton the obligatory one
or two weeks to start and especially
that first week is a tough
ask and then we see fields in there
because yes uh pat mahomes sat
for for a year they were scoring 30
points a game in kansas city they were
one of the highest scoring offenses in
the league there's no way that andy
dawson bears
are going to be one of the highest
scoring offenses of the week what about
trey lance
what do you think his rookie season
looks like do you see maybe he mount
wide
maybe he's uh next to uh jimmy g or he's
just
way too valuable um a future quarterback
in this league to
throw him out there like that and he'll
just be a clipboard holder
uh for as long as uh they want to stick
with jimmy g
what do you think most of these guys i
feel like it's up it's up to them like
it's trey lance's job essentially to win
in camp they spend this offseason
evaluating and teaching and you know you
know how it is but it's go
time once you're about three or four
days into camp and if he is as good as
they think he is i think he'll be
starting as soon as
as week one i mean if he um is a little
more accurate than than he was in
college that the amount of
uh talent on that roster is breathtaking
to me they are one of the favorite i'm
i'm kind of surprised when i saw like
that
right now the rams are number two nfc
favorite if you're just kind of going by
uh what's in the desert and everything
and and to me i i don't see the rams as
being particularly better
this year there's a lot of reasons to
think they'll decline outside of the
quarterback position
and the 49ers and the seahawks and that
division is just
so loaded we've seen kyle shanahan
with a similar type of quarterback in
rg3 light up the league as a rookie and
i don't really see any reason why he
would be afraid to play trey lance as
long as he has a good auger
all right i'll push back on the rams
thing greg because uh uh you know
uh there there was ever since that uh
you know that monday nighter where the
rams
um and the chiefs killed defense right
supposedly
and then the super bowl was played and
there was only one touchdown scored
um the rams offense hasn't been the same
since then and they seem to have been
missing as
a gear and no matter how beautiful a
ball that jared goff can throw
it just seemed that there was just uh
uh a certain gear that was missing
on that and it might have been girly not
being uh as
as you know healthy as we were all you
know hoping for it could have been that
but the fact that they do have a running
game that that
that uh you know stafford's never had
the receiving core
is is you could say the same if not
maybe better
why don't you like the rams to improve
this year
because i i don't think the defense is
going to stay at the same level
generally defenses that good don't stay
at the same level
it's much easier to have a great
consistent offense
so that that's one area you think about
who they lost
in the secondary they're going to miss
josh johnson they're going to miss
uh troy hill they're going to miss three
defensive coaches it wasn't just
you know brandon steele it was aubrey
pleasant it was the coordinator who's
now in
in green bay barry and you look at their
roster and it's an
ultimate like stars and scrubs roster
like how bad can your defense be when
you have aaron donald and jalen ramsey
it's not like they're going to be bad
but there are a lot of positions where
they're average
or below average and they are counting
on their ability
to develop and they've done a good job
with that over the years but they have
lost so much in terms of their coaching
staff they didn't add anything to their
offensive line i just think
you're really counting on a big upgrade
from going
from goff who at times uh was a good
quarterback and certainly was not last
year
uh to a top ten type of quarterback in
stafford but not a top five guy not not
one of the best quarterbacks in the
league
and you're in a loaded division and i
think if you just look at the roster
like
one through ten the rams stack up
against anyone but they're not as thin
they've been very lucky in terms of
injuries over the last couple years
one of the least injured teams in the in
the league i just feel like there's
there's a lot of reasons to believe like
they're going to battle to win 10 or 11
games that nfc west is gonna just be a
bloodbath greg rosenthal here on the
rich eisen show
and uh we're still waiting to see um
fifth year options
turn into um monster contracts
for lamar and baker why haven't we seen
them yet
do we do we get them right before the
season what do you think
yeah this is the time of year i think
it's going to happen with lamar jackson
just because of the way that he
spoke about it he sounded so confident
and i would anticipate it's probably
going to happen with baker mayfield
when when the players aren't stressing
publicly and the agents aren't stressing
at all i don't think the fans should
because they i think both players
would be agitating if they weren't
expecting to sign lamar
i think will happen before camp whether
baker happens before camp or midway
through
it it sounds like it's happening i i
thought it might be an interesting
strategy after watching jared goff and
jared you know carson let's get those
two
contracts early and then regret it uh to
just make baker play another six seven
games with kevin stefanski but it
doesn't sound like the browns are that
interested in doing that i don't want
the browns could be
so special this year greg are you on
that hype
bandwagon what do you got for me on the
browns
i am we sort of live and die uh with the
browns with mark sessler on their
podcast
you know a long time fan i just worry
it's the nfl it's like yes
everything makes sense they they have a
top five roster
um but we've seen teams like that goats
like it wouldn't shock me if they go ten
and seven a couple things go wrong for
them they
they should be right there with every
team uh in the afc and i love the fact
that they're built on an offensive
line that just is back and it's loaded
they have so many
different ways that they can beat you
with offense they have the best
backfield in the league they have one of
the best tight end groups in the league
and now with obj back
like i love the receivers too davinci
has to kind of prove that he's not matt
nagy though
that he's not like first year coach of
the year type type of guy and and
he keeps the magic going because
defenses will definitely adjust in that
well maybe it's just that baker is a
little bit better than trubisky maybe
what do you think about that
if you want to keep if you want to make
an analogy here maybe maybe
maybe stefanski's got the better
quarterback of the two yeah you know
i think he does i mean i know he does
he's got the better quarterback
the question is like is baker gonna be
the guy from the last six games of the
year
i i was a little surprised like this off
season it still feels like the question
is like
is baker a difference maker it's like
watch those playoff games i mean i know
they lost to the chiefs but some of the
throws he made in those games were
outrageous i mean he he played fantastic
for the last seven or eight games can he
do that for a full 16 game season
there's like a pretty good reason to
believe he will and
i just love his demeanor i love the way
that he play calls he he definitely
feels a little bit like an afc answer to
kyle shanahan and and that's
beautiful for brown's fan too among many
things they're annoyed that kyle
shanahan got away i mean i mean how do
you handle that sesslers that browns fan
hands us as a jet fan i mean
you know is hanzo's doing the usual
which is you know just what we're all
doing which is like
you know uh what else we're back here
again where we're hoping the coach and
the quarterback's right you know
like i said earlier you know i like the
coach the the quarterback concerns me
that
they they either drafted a
generationally talented guy finally
or they drafted stiffler and his mother
i'm genuinely concerned about that
greg there's no gray area i don't think
honestly i love that i hate the i hate
to
you know i grew up a patriots fan too i
mean there is a part of me that is
curious to see if this all just blows up
in the jets
in style possible but man you you got to
love the coach and you got to love the
talent on offense like
they if joe douglas hadn't fixed that
offensive line by now
um after the investments that he's made
um i'd be surprised
and i love the weapons around um
you know i love the weapons around the
quarterback i really think that
right now the jets are set up where like
six seven wins you got to be happy with
that rich right i mean
there shouldn't be too high as long as
the offense and the quarterback are good
i'd worry about the wins later there's
now a 17th game out there greg
so you know maybe expectations can go a
little higher but i do like the coach
and i i hope that they did
get it right with the quarterback and i
i do agree that joe douglas is is
building from the inside out as opposed
to what was going on
in the administrations before despite my
uh just
pure man love for jamal adams i i i do
like the way that they're building the
team
um thanks for the call greg let's do
this close to the beginning of the
season and
like as always i'm more than happy to be
the home or the away team for the home
and home
with on your pod absolutely yeah we
gotta get you on soon anytime uh
look forward to talking to you again
richard right back at you greg that's
greg rosenthal around the nfl podcast
it is highly entertaining highly popular
and um
it's where all podcasts are acquired hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here